bonjour marc fesneau merci beaucoup on
joue aux lettres est notre invité
politique ce matin ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement et de la
participation citoyenne en détention
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
qui dirige le bureau par exemple la voix
du nord bonjour je viens bonjour oriane
bonjour monsieur ministre bonjour et
monsieur le ministre on va commencer
évidemment pas ce qui c'est parfait hier
au large de calais ou 27 migrants ont
donc trouvé la mort dans le naufrage de
leur embarcation l'eau est ce que selon
vous ce drame était évitable
weblin drames de cette nature là par
nature on cherche à l'éviter est ce
qu'il était et évita en tout cas les
conditions actuelles créée par la
situation de ces migrants encore la
situation créée par les passeurs
par la difficulté dialogue aussi avec
avec le nombre nos amis britanniques
tout ça crée des conditions dont on voit
que en plus dans cette période pré
hivernale où les conditions maritimes
sont beaucoup plus difficiles vous le
savez mieux que moi créé les conditions
que des drames comme cela arrive c'est
ce que l'on craignons nous avons pour ya
plus de plusieurs milliers de migrants
qui ont essayé de passer qui ont été
sauvées ces derniers mois et ces
dernières semaines le président la
république d'abord il faut s'incliner
devant les victimes cd père des
personnes des parfois des très jeunes
parfois des mineurs qui sont morts au
milieu de la manche qui venait souvent
d'irak et de syrie qui avaient déjà sans
doute traversé d'étape péril tout ça
accompagné par des gens qui se parlent
de l'expression mais qui se greffe sur
le dos de la misère humaine et qui à
chaque étape viennent leur prélever leur
dîme
et donc et donc il faut à la fois penser
aujourd'hui et ce matin aux victimes l
émotion que nous ressentons tous devant
ces drames jima parce que tous derrière
tout ça il ya des réalités humaines et
des gens qui avaient une histoire qui
avait une vie qui ont quitté leur pays
pour des tas de raisons souvent
politiques ou de persécution et puis
désormais au delà de l'émotion qui est
légitime il faut que nous arrivions à
travailler avec les britanniques sur
quelque chose autour d'eux des affaires
de l'accord du touquet qui fasse en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas un appel d'air
de main d'oeuvre dans ces pédants nous
en grande bretagne et que par ailleurs
nous arrivions à coopérer avec les
anglais parce qu'on peut pas être les
seuls à exercer le
serge goulet ce fait nous risquons
n'arrivent pas vraiment au bout d'un
d'un système on a vu depuis depuis 2018
une sécurisation accrue de la frontière
et pourtant chaque année le nombre de
tentatives de passage augmente ça veut
dire que finalement la sécurisation ne
fonctionne ne fonctionne pas et si on
sécurise de plus en plus on va lutter
contre les passeurs évidemment c'est
bien logique mais ça ne suffira pas
ne suffit pas est-ce qu'il faut remettre
en cause très sincère très clairement
les accords du tout il faut rediscuter
avec les britanniques parce que
manifestement lors il ya toujours les
grandes déclarations faut remettre en
cause des accords du touquet en tout cas
il faut discuter avec les britanniques
pour savoir les conditions dans
lesquelles on peut faire en sorte qu'on
se retrouve pas dans une situation
malgré les c'est la france qui prend à
sa charge même si normalement les
britanniques doivent prendre une partie
de la charge qui est la nôtre celle de
le garder les frontières si je peux dire
il faut qu'on regarde avec les
britanniques les moyens pour faire en
sorte que ce qu'on voit effectivement à
l'oeuf c'est à dire plutôt vers un
accroissement est quelque chose qui fait
que des gens sur le sol français ont
envie à toute force d'aller sur le
territoire britannique donc il ya un
travail à faire avec les britanniques et
j'en conviens reste le principal souci
monsieur fait nous c'est que il n'ya
plus véritablement de voies légales
d'immigration elle s'est réduite encore
plus avec avec le breakbeat et c'est ce
qui fait que le cpu
autrement on voit bien tous est allé au
brésil et c'est pas parce qu'on a quitté
l'espace européen en termes
institutionnels qu'on n'a pas des
responsabilités y compris quand on est
britannique et je pense que c'est
d'ailleurs l'appel au dialogue qu'à
l'ancien président de la république il
faut qu'on regarde avec les britanniques
ils ont des responsabilités et nous
avons ce sujet en partage ce n'est pas
chacun à côté de la frontière où on se
regarde et on fait en sorte comme think
de nos de fer qu'il n'y ait pas de
problème il ya des problèmes de
migration il ya des problèmes avec des
drames humains on en a un terrible sous
les yeux ce matin avec ce qui s'est
passé hier dans la journée et donc on a
une responsabilité collective c'est ce à
quoi appelle le président de la
république c'est de regarder
posément mais sérieusement cette
question qu'ils fassent en sorte que
n'est pas un appel d'air côté
britannique et qu'on soit pas seul et
que les britanniques prennent leur part
de de la charge et de la responsable et
les britanniques mais gérald darmanin
mystère de l'intérieur hier soir
pointait aussi la responsabilité
d'autres pays est ce que les pays-bas
est ce que la belgique font aussi leur
part du travail il faut
la réunion qui va être organisé
aujourd'hui une réunion qui ne réunit
pas que les français les britanniques
mais aussi d'autres pays
qui doivent prendre leur part aussi pour
faire en sorte de lui à leur échelle et
dans leur territoire contre les passeurs
et contre ces flux migratoires ce qui me
font passer
si le sujet était ainsi le si le sujet
était simple et facile ça serait donc
moi je vous mais vous pensez que la
présidence française ça peut faire
avancer ce dossier je sais pas si c'est
seulement la présidence française faut
pas attendre une présidence française
seulement pour faire avancer ce dossier
d'ailleurs ne sommes pas encore sous
présidence française et nous essayons de
faire avancer ce dossier depuis des mois
avec les avec les britanniques et c'est
vrai que la sphère du british n'a pas
simplifié les choses mais il faut qu'on
regarde avec les autres pays européens
qui sont concernés par ce par ce sujet
et migratoire parce qu'ils gagnent il ya
des flux migratoires sur le continent
aussi il ya des organisations et des
passeurs sur le continent et c'est aussi
dans ce domaine là qu'il faut travailler
c'est ce qu' il peut y avoir des
réponses franco-française et la question
des quotas d'immigration qui revient sur
le devant de la table c'est notamment
des propositions des candidats droite on
se souvient qu emmanuel macron n'avait
parlé que les doigts philippe en avait
parlé à l'époque où il était premier
ministre avec des quotas d'immigration
fixé chaque année par le parlement pour
les migrations économiques pourquoi ça
n'a pas été fait écoutez on a fait une
première chose qui est à l'oeuvre et qui
petit à petit est en train de
s'améliorer c'était de faire en sorte
que le traitement des demandeurs d'asile
le traitement des gens qui sont en
situation de demande de vida de visa
pardon que le délai de traitement soit
le plus court possible et ramenés à des
délais qui soient raisonnables pourquoi
réseau l'un parce que quand vous laisser
des gens dans des situations
d'instabilité de statut non pas pendant
des mois mais parfois pendant des années
vous installez des gens avec des
familles après vous êtes dans la
situation de ne plus au fond pouvoir les
reconduire à la frontière donc on avait
besoin de raccourcir les délais 2 pensez
que c'est dans les simples frontières
franco française on réglera ses sujets
migratoires on voit bien les la crise
que nous avons aux frontières polonaise
avec la biélorussie évidemment c'est un
sujet européen donc c'est peut pas dire
que c'est franco français il faut qu'on
est au niveau européen
à la fois dans les mesures de protection
de nos frontières frontex dont il faut
sans doute renforcer les moyens mais
aussi en terme de règles c'est à dire
qu'on peut pas avoir autant de
disparités entre les pays européens
parce qu'évidemment les migrants pour
beaucoup d'entre eux ils vont pour ils
quittent leur pays pour des raisons
économiques et pour des raisons
politiques et pour des raisons de
persécution personne ne prend ses
valises et quitte g soit pour le plaisir
je ne connais pas de gens qui fassent ça
pour le plaisir c'est des gens qui ont
parfois y compris même la mort aux
trousses et donc si nous n'avons pas une
réponse collective à la fois quand il ya
de l'asile et qu'il faut traiter les
demandes d'asile parce qu'il ya des gens
qui ont besoin d'asile ya deux des gens
qui ont besoin d'être protégée peut pas
à la fois
pousser des cris d'orfraie à juste titre
sur des pays qui tourne dans un certain
nombre de domaines à la dictature à la
persécution fait à telle ou telle
religion ou aux femmes et après ne pas
prendre nos propres responsabilités en
de mon terme de demande d'asile en a
besoin de ce point de vue là et c'est
pas une question de quotas en france
dont nous sommes la seule frontière ce
qu'il faut par pour reprendre les
questions européennes est-ce qu'il faut
pas reprendre la main sur la politique
migratoire
changer la constitution pour permettre
aussi de fixer des des quotas on le
disait mais aussi peut se permettre deux
jeux déroger aux règles européennes si
comme si la constitution était une forme
de prophétie auto réalisatrice et parce
qu'on déciderait dans la constitution
qui aura plus d'immigration il y aura
plus d'immigration enfin je veux dire
qu'ils sérieusement peut penser ça il ya
parfois des besoins d'ajustement
constitutionnel mais ne pas régler le
problème en se disant on va pas dresser
des murs entre l'allemagne et la france
une fois que les gens sont en allemagne
ils essaieront de passer il aussi rond
si de passer la frontière et dont on a
besoin de traiter au niveau européen
cette question là on n'a pas besoin de
la traiter seulement dans nos frontières
et par ailleurs sur le sujet à chaque
fois qu'on a un problème si à chaque
fois qu'on a un problème sur le sujet en
france on considère qu'il faut sortir
des traités européens on est devant on a
devant nous un grave problème ça veut
dire que les solutions préconisées
notamment par certains candidats ont
tous les candidats des répliques ans à
défaut sur lui mais moi je je je vois
bien le jeu qui consiste dans une
primaire à être le plus radicale
possible et à faire parfois des
propositions et je le regrette au fond
parce que dans le débat démocratique on
a besoin de dire des choses je crois que
l'un des candidats d'ailleurs l'a dit
dire des choses qu'on peut faire dire
des choses qui sont crédibles devant les
citoyens parce que les mêmes qui vous
disais ça ils ont été en situation de
gouverner ya dix ans il faisait les
mêmes rodomontades ils se sont heurtés
aux mêmes difficultés donc plutôt que
d'essayer
à toute force de détourner le sujet en
disant il suffit de changer la
constitution comme si tu y crois
sérieusement qu'en changeant un article
de la constitution va régler le problème
de flux migratoires qui sont liés à des
problèmes de population qui sont
persécutés dans leur pays
quand vous attend vous avez la mort aux
trousses
et c'est ce n'est pas notre nous notre
chance ce n'est pas d'être dans cette
situation mais quand vous êtes syriens
ou irakiens que vous êtes persécuté pour
votre religion quand vous êtes une femme
ac d'organes et que vous voulez quitter
votre pays c'est pas la peine de chez
eux ce n'est pas en changeant la
constitution que vous allez changer on a
besoin revanche qu'au niveau européen on
traite ces questions aux frontières on
regarde la manière dont on harmonise nos
politiques et quand il a besoin d'asile
de l'exercer parce que c'est la
responsabilité de nos démocraties et de
notre de nos pays que dead d'exercer et
de faire exercer le droit d'asile est
par ailleurs quand des gens ne sont sur
le territoire et non pas motif à y est
de les reconduire à la frontière mais
c'est une politique collectif qu'on doit
voir on va parler de la crise sanitaire
oui autre sujet d'actualité
aujourd'hui devrait s'exprimer
le ministre de la santé olivier verrons
pour annoncer un renforcement des
mesures alors c'est vrai que le 31 août
on nous disait je l'entends encore le
premier ministre nous dire qu'on était
sur le bon chemin d'un retour à la vie
normale est ce qu'on doit faire le deuil
de cette de ce retour à la vie normale
doit pas faire le deuil de la un retour
à la vie normale on doit on doit en tout
cas est principalement être vigilant
parce qu'il faut qu'on adapte nos outils
nos dispositifs nos politiques à la
situation virale c'est quand même une
épidémie qui nous aura appris
collectivement et paco gouvernants
d'ailleurs c'est ce serait bien que ça
s'applique à tout le monde une forme
d'humilité
avec des phase épidémique qui ont été de
nature diverse avec des pays dont on
disait qu'on cité en exemple dont on
disait que c'était formidable et on voit
qu'ils se heurtent de nouveaux eux-mêmes
adhésif d un pic épidémique beaucoup
plus puissant que le nôtre donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut éviter de se donner
des leçons réciproque sur ce sujet là on
voit bien en revanche qu'on est dans une
dans une nouvelle vague épidémique avec
une montée en puissance des cas pas
complètement corrélés comme ça a été
dans les précédents épisodes avec des
hospitalisations ou sylvain massive
roues des soins intensifs sursaturé
simplement il faut qu'on depuis le début
on bute sur la même difficulté nous mais
comme tous les pays du monde avec une
un ajustement qu'il faut y avoir entre
les cadres de gens qui sont contaminés
les personnes qui sont en réanimation
dans le service hospitalier pour ne pas
saturer les services hospitaliers et
c'est ce à quoi il faut qu'on fasse face
alors avec un élément nouveau par
rapport au précédent pic épidémique
c'est la vaccination c'est un outil
puissant la vaccination et c'est pour ça
que le président de la république dans
sa déclaration mauduit a massivement
inciter à la vaccination on va loin vers
la vaccination des enfants le ministre a
je vais vous répondre mais juste je
finis sur ce sujet le ministre le
ministre véran le premier ministre hier
avec les parlementaires le groupe du
sénat est le groupe les groupes du sénat
le président du sénat les groupes de
l'assemblée nationale le président
national national ont consulté on vient
sur la table un certain nombre de
propositions ce matin c'est les
associations d'élus les représentants
syndicaux les représentants de
l'éducation nationale le ministère ans
s'exprimera à la mi journée mais
effectivement dans le dal arsenal qui
est le nôtre et la question des gestes
barrières sur les plaines il faut qu'on
réapprenne notre vigilance collective ce
qui concerne le mans mais tout le monde
oui enfin personne n'est parfait il peut
arriver à vous à moi à n'importe qui
parce que nous sommes des êtres humains
et pas des robots que l'on puisse
oublier qu'on puisse se relâcher parce
qu'au fond effectivement la vie est
devenue un peu plus normal qu'elle ne
l'était au mois de mars 2001 ok même pas
de leçon à donner mais attend une
vigilance pour tout le monde et donc on
aura besoin de faire ça et puis
d'accélérer le rappel vaccinal parce
qu'on voit bien on savait depuis le
début d'ailleurs qui a besoin
d'accélérer les processus de rappel
vaccinaux par ailleurs pour les enfants
il ya des il ya des dépositions qui ont
été prises par des agences américaines
du médicament au niveau européen on
verra on va faire comme on l'a fait à
chaque fois c'est à dire qu' il ya des
process il ya des hautes autorités et ça
donne du crédit à la politique qu'on
donne qui donnent leur avis et à partir
de là on prendra des dc ceci se passe au
parlement ces derniers jours alors il
est beaucoup de questions de budget hier
le parlement a voté l'indemnité
inflation qui était promise par jean
castex cette indemnité de 100 euros qui
s'est inversée à 38 millions de français
votée mais le sénat l'avait rejeté
jugeant le dispositif mal ciblé la
droite la gauche critique une injustice
dans le fait que les revenus des ménages
ne sont pas pris en compte accepte une
allocation une des unités qui est
individualisé pourquoi ne pas avoir
écouté l'opposition doit avoir cherché
un compromis alors je veux pas mettre
qui que ce soit en défaut de crédibilité
ou de responsabilité mais les mêmes nous
demander qu'on baisse les taxes
uniformément pour tout le monde alors je
sais pas où était la justice parce que
là c'était plus 38 millions c'était 65
millions de francs cfa
globalement tous n'ont pas leur permis
de conduire qui était concerné donc les
mêmes qui viennent vous faire le
reproche d'avoir ciblé 10 il fallait sur
cible et en même temps tandis que dans
le même mouvement si je peux dire avec
la plus grande cohérence qu'ils soient
sans doute il nous expliquait que le
seule voix c'était baisser les taxes ce
qui est le la chose la plus uniforme
qu'ils soient sans aucune
distinction entre les revenus ces choix
qui a été fait par le gouvernement
pourquoi parce qu'on a ciblé parce qu'à
force de dire
on élimine un certain nombre de
catégories de population ces populations
qui sont en nous qu'on appelle la classe
moyenne même si je n'aime pas la
terminologie elle a toujours le
sentiment qu'elle passe à côté des
dispositifs et quand vous gagnez 2000
euros quand vous avez une augmentation
de 2 des prix des carburants ou des prix
du chauffage de cette nature là ça pèse
aussi sur vos revenus donc il faut il
faut aussi considérer cette position là
le gouvernement avec sa position
l'opposition au sénat comme ailleurs a
le droit d'en avoir une autre simplement
je demande un peu qu'on puisse être
cohérent parce que moi j'ai entendu des
voix au tout début de ce process nous
réclamant une baisse uniforme des taxes
et maintenant on nous dit assez pour
mieux cibler banon une baisse des taxes
n'étaient pas nature pas ciblé l'autre
question qui concerne le budget budget
rejeté ici au sénat avant même la fin de
son examen la droite sénatoriale qui
juge ce budget électoraliste qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de cette méthode
par nature vous savez je suis ministre
des relations avec le parlement est par
nature j'ai grand respect du sénat en
plus et c'est pas d'ma propos de
comptoir parce que je je donne donc pas
commenter les décisions d'une majorité
qui s'impose à nous et qui s'impose
d'ailleurs à d'autres parlementaires au
sénat à d'autres sénateurs qui
manifestement n'était pas sur cette
ligne là si j'ai bien regardé le détail
des votes seule chose c'est que je pense
que
un budget ça mérite forcément me
semble-t-il un débat je trouve que c'est
toujours utile et d'ailleurs au fond on
a remplacé un débat budgétaire par des
débats non budgétaires sur des thèmes
qui étaient des thèmes budgétaire alors
puisque j'étais en conférence des
présidents mercredi que le travail
thématiques voilà c'était débats
thématiques mais pendant qu'on soit la
question de la politique
environnementale de la politique
économique et sociale de la politique à
l'endroit des collectivités locales tout
sujet qu'on traite généralement dans là
aussi dans la deuxième partie avec quoi
de la politique quand vous de la part de
la droite peut-être mais après tout
c'est la décision du sénat elle est
souveraine on a adapté le calendrier en
bonne intelligence avec le sénat pour
qu'il puisse y avoir un partage jour
redistribue si je peux dire du temps
parlementaire
mais si à chaque fois qu'on a un épisode
électoral on dit c'est électoraliste je
ne sais pas d'ailleurs qui est
électoraliste dans la ferme est en tout
cas je pense qu'on fait bien voix de
sénatoriales r ce propos il me semble
que le débat budgétaire mérite un débat
budgétaire et que ça permettait
d'ailleurs à chacun de faire état de ses
propres propositions mais après tout
c'est un choix on en prend acte et il y
aura des débats non budgétaires mais il
y aura des débats quand même bon sens
malgré tout que les relations entre le
sénat et le gouvernement ne sont ne sont
pas simples non jamais été toutes façons
durant ce mandat ou c'est que président
du sénat gérard larcher a écrit une
lettre à jean castex pour pointer un
certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
dans les relations entre le gouvernement
et le sénat justement est en pointe en
l'absence de certains ministres bruno le
maire olivier ferrand et ce qui est la
raison de pointer sa mairie dans son
rôle il a raison de pointer camp
quand il ya des dysfonctionnements de
les pointer les indiqué au pays andin
attendez et quand ils pointent des
dysfonctionnements qui parfois des
questions et des questions écrites
auxquelles il n'est pas donné une
réponse dans les délais suffisants moi
mon rôle c'est de faire en sorte qu'il
ya des dysfonctionnements qu'il ya des
absences qui sont marqués bruno le maire
hier était aux questions gouvernement de
rappeler mes collègues du gouvernement
cités d'être présent à l'assemblée
nationale au sénat reconnaissons sic on
a été dans une phase épidémique a mis
tout le monde en tension enfin je veux
dire les ministres sont à l'oeuvre ils
sont à l'oeuvre à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat ils sont à l'oeuvre ailleurs
simplement il faut qu'on essaie de
trouver un terrain de bonne intelligence
pour faire en sorte que les exigences
qui sont légitimes d'une assemblée comme
le sénat soit respectée et que par
ailleurs on comprenne aussi les
contingences et les contraintes des uns
et des autres mon travail comme unis des
relations avec le parlement c'est bien m
de la fluidité dans tout cela et faire
en sorte de répondre aux attentes du
président du staff ou toujours écouté
quand le président du sénat a écrit un
courrier au premier ministre et qu'il a
un certain nombre de demandes de
prérequis ou de griller leurs attentes
et bp pas simplement poliment un oui
c'est ça c'est plus reçu est bien prise
ne s'est pas simplement accusé de
réception qu'il faut faire c'est un vrai
accusé de réception c'est on a bien
compris le message on va faire passer
les messages qu'il faut personne n'est
parfait non plus donc vous avez rappelé
il faut que non mais on a été en charge
très longuement la sur la question de la
crise épidémique depuis mars 2020 et il
y avait une autre épisode avant le
gouvernement est alors sur des tas de
sujets et des tas de sujets sur lesquels
on essaie de répondre aux questions il
peut y avoir des moments où il ya du
relâchement sur les délais de réponse
aux questions écrites et je rappelle
chaque fois mes collègues à leur
obligation de deux dernières questions
parlementaires avant de parler de la
campagne présidentielle avec julien le
texte sur l'allongement du dell l'égal
du vg de douze à quatorze semaines sera
examiné la semaine prochaine par les
députés c'est un texte qui divise la
majorité
christophe castaner a voulu qu'il soit
inscrit au calendrier du parlement d'ici
la fin de l'année est ce qu'il a eu
raison quelle est votre position sur ce
texte c'est sur une semaine d'initiative
parlementaire et jinan une semaine du
groupe donc c'est le droit du groupe en
marché des groupes majoritaires de
l'inscrire à l'ordre du jour olivier
ferrand extrêmement à la position du
gouvernement je pense que
celle qui il exprimera lundi la position
du gouvernement je ne viens pas présenté
sur le terrain des autres mais la
position du gouvernement était assez
simple c'est que d'abord de d'entourer
cette question là d'un certain nombre
d'avis le ccn et enfin un certain nombre
d'avis qui n'était pas acquis à l'époque
d'avoir un débat avec les parlementaires
de regarder quelles sont les limites qui
sont fournis finalement le débat et les
îles et sur quoi en tout cas de ce que
j'en ai compris n'étant pas forcément
une spécialiste de la question c'est au
fond la volonté d'allongement elle est
liée au fait qu'on estime à juste titre
d'ailleurs que sa troupe de femmes ne
peuvent pas recourir à libérer pour des
raisons de délais je pense que ça pose
un problème moi personnellement qui est
plus lourd qui est dans des territoires
au gansu
densité de médecins qui peuvent traiter
de ces questions là ça n'est pas
seulement en allongeant les délais qu'on
réglera le sujet de femmes qui de toute
façon sont éloignés de médecins quand
vous avez dans le territoire que je
connais mais la région centre val de
loire entre 15 et 20% dès gens qui n'ont
pas de médecin traitant quand vous êtes
confronté à la décision douloureuse
difficile de une interruption volontaire
de grossesse et que vous n'avez pas de
médecin traitant qui vous en parler au
fond et la question du délai ne résume
pas la seule question la seule question
parce que c'est un droit c'est que le
droit puisse s'exercer quel que soit le
délai je pense qu'on a une obligation
collective il est question de
démographie médicale ne sont pas des
leviers de cette question là de faire en
sorte que toutes les femmes puissent
avoir accès à un conseil à un médecin et
un avis et marc fesneau dernière
question sur le parlement puisque à
l'initiative des sénateurs centristes
ici au sénat a été voté un texte pour
revenir sur le non cumul des mandats est
ce que ce texte va poursuivre son chemin
parlementaire s qui sera examiné la
faune bailleval poursuivre puisqu'il est
dans la niche du groupe u10
pas la semaine prochaine après demain
demain ce que nous sommes et demain à
l'assemblée nationale et après
moi ce que je pense sur ce sujet là
intéressant quand on a ouvert le débat
moi je ne suis pas d'accord avec l'idée
que
la vie politique serait profondément
transformé par le simple idée qu'on
revienne la fonction de député maire
alors on dit dix mille 10 mythes ses 95
% des communes c'est à dire qu'on
revient au cumul de mandats je pense
qu'on a re
complexifier les choses en disant qu'on
a autorise aussi le cumul des indemnités
je pense que ça n'est pas une bonne idée
en revanche la question du lien entre
les parlementaires députés et sénateurs
et je les dis à très longtemps je
l'avais dès la sortie de la crise des
gels et je manque je suis assez solide
sur mes convictions et de trop de
retrouver un nouveau lien parce qu'en
fait on a fait une feinte de cumul sèche
qui a fait que des distorsions se sont
créés et parfois entre les territoires
et les élus nationaux et donc il faut
qu'on trouve ce lien est ce que c'est
par la voix du député maire ou de
sénateur maire est ce que c'est pas par
la voie du fait qu'on fasse trop rentrer
dans les exécutifs des parlementaires il
me semble que c'est un sujet qui mérite
d'être posé qui sera pas exclue écumez
complètement par le débat parlementaire
de cette semaine et 2 je pense que ça
pose un problème plus global du
fonctionnement de nos démocraties et de
notre démocratie je pense que c'est un
débat pardon qui relèvent à six mois
d'une présidentielle à peine d'un débat
démocratique et donc d'un d'aimables de
campagne présidentielle quand même
présidentielle d'août on va parler et
aussi de transition merci beaucoup
monsieur fait de vouloir et on va parler
au sein de cette présidentielle de la
constitution d'un nouvel enfant
politique la maison commune alors il va
falloir nous préciser à quoi il
ressemble cet enfant là on a compris qui
sera portée sur les fonts baptismaux
lundi
à la maison de la mutualité il va réunir
le modem agir et l'hérault m et le
nouveau parti des douars philippe
horizons mais voilà est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire concrètement à quoi il
va servir dans ce nouvel ensemble
ensemble citoyens dès leur sens il me
semble qu'il ya une double volonté qui
s'exprime au travers de ce rassemblement
où vous auriez pu rajouter territoire de
progrès ou en commun ou d'autres
formations politiques que fondent
allemand envie de s'adjoindre à cette
démarche n a une double volonté il une
volonté d'abord à s'inscrivant dans la
logique de 2017 que ceux et celles qui
soutiennent la politique menée par le
président de la république
puisse se retrouver dans le même
ensemble c'est à dire faire figurer et
rendre visibles dépassement qui est à
l'oeuvre depuis 2010 est ce qu'au fond
depuis 2010 est le champ politique n'a
pas beaucoup changé la création d'un
marché puis deux sur le flanc droit sur
le flanc gauche et même dans l'espace
majoritaire il ya eu peu de mouvements
et de changement d'un point de vue
partisan donc premiers éléments c'est
faire figurer au travers de cet ensemble
le dépassement et puis deuxième élément
dans cette construction
s'était dit d'ailleurs
chat ferrand ou même récemment par
edouard philippe sella capacité à
l'intérieur de ces ensembles à ce que
ceux qui se reconnaissent plus tôt comme
venant plutôt de la droite ceux qui se
reconnaissent plus tôt vous convenant de
l'espace central puissent eux-mêmes
s'organiser et solidifier leur l'alors
lors leurs bases moi je pense qu' il n'y
aurait il n'y a jamais de dépassement
c'est à dire la capa le dépassement
c'est quoi c'est la capacité pour des
gens qui viennent de frontières et
d'horizons différents en l'occurrence
droite et gauche il n'y a pas de
possibilités de dépassement dans ce pays
si l'espace central n'est pas fort
françois bayrou avait failli réussir en
2007 le président de la république
emmanuel macron l'a réussi en 2017
mais c'est parce que sur l'espace
central il ouvre un champ sinon vous
n'auriez pas trouvé un certain nombre de
gens adorent parler visiblement c'est
pas c'est pas un grand parti central
comme le rêvait françois françois bayrou
ça va être plus tôt
une sorte de bannière commune qui va
servir aussi disons le très
politiquement parlant à
organiser les législatives à servir de
salle de réunion pour pour investir les
candidats non ça n'est pas une bannière
parce que si c'était une bannière on
aurait fait une bannière cétacés
sincères entre le berger la bannière me
disait un ministre et oui et donc ce
n'est pas une bannière et l'idée c'est
de respectant pas ce que moi je n'ai pas
oublié ce que nous avions dit en tout
cas pour ce qui est du mouvement
démocrate à l'époque c'était en 2002 que
on mettait pas tout le monde dans le
même parti si on pensait pas exactes qui
ont pensé pas exactement la même chose
là l'idée c'est de rassembler au travers
d'une structure des gens qui se
retrouvent sur la politique et qui se
retrouvent dans le dépassement prônée
par le président de la république mais
par ailleurs ça n'empêche pas qu'à
l'intérieur de ces ensembles aider ce
qu'on appelle des coopérations avancées
ont renforcé de la mrc très rapidement
julian des passants
on a vu le comité exécutif de cette
maison commune richard ferrand jean
castex edouard philippe herman cain où
sont les femmes bayrou françois bayrou
sont livrés le comité exécutif sera
paritaire alors vous donc c'est bien les
quatre têtes pensantes c'est pourquoi si
le toit de l'appareil
sur le premier ministre les anciens 1er
du présent arrêt pub merci marc merci
beaucoup on a arrêté ce
matin
[Musique]